Human DNA information was confirmed in the taiyaki.
Human dua dadi information has been analyzed.
Coincidentally, I was matched with a Japanese person at an animation studio in Suginami.  I
'm in charge of the production desk
That's how it was called It might be possible to identify a virus that is effective against giant creatures from past medical history
No, that's impossible.
I found a company car that
was
thought to
be abandoned by Chiba City.  Well
, show me the language of Nichiryoshin, it's
terrible, are you going to take money with this?
No
, it doesn't seem like he threw himself in. It seems that he was playing a smartphone game while walking
here.
Three days ago, it was talked about on social media that a rare monster had first appeared near Seiko in Miya.
I wondered if he had more misfortune in this area after the restoration of the original painting, so he
should have walked earlier and put up a sign prohibiting smartphones.